what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here today so a
little late to this we i was up late at
night editing some videos from that prey
premiere i think they turned out really
well if you're interested at all please
go ahead and check it out but we got
ourselves a short
short short trailer for joker
2. haven't seen it yet but of course i
want to talk about it my fiance olivia
is the one who told me about it and she
got excited because it plays the song
cheek to cheek here that's all i know
about it because she's a big fred
astaire ginger rogers fan that song was
made famous in the movie top hat got a
friendly reminder about that which
automatically started making my mind
churning some more because i already
have so many thoughts about what this
movie might actually do thoughts that i
think are a little bit different than
what i hear most people saying about it
i'm sure some things that i'm thinking
are very similar to what others have
been saying but there's aspects to where
i feel like this movie might be
exploring that i haven't heard
commentator on yet maybe i just missed
it but i'm curious to hear what you guys
think
about what i'm thinking about what this
movie might be trying to attempt with
the relationship with joker and harleen
quinzel especially knowing some details
about where this movie's primarily gonna
be taking place knowing that it's gonna
be a musical just knowing the song cheek
to cheek is in here actually got my mind
going some more because i was like wait
that actually lines up so much more with
where i was thinking this movie might
actually go but before that i gotta
watch this short teaser trailer and see
what the imagery is like here i remember
when the first little bits of footage
came out for joker it wasn't even from
the actual film it was a test and that
immediately gave us kind of a sense of
what this movie might end up feeling
like so i'm kind of hoping that this
will do the same thing because it's only
18 seconds my god that's short all right
let's watch it leave a like
let's get to it
[Music]
october 4th 2024 i like that arthur
fleck laugh at the end all right well
actually you know skimming through this
there's a lot of this imagery that i
really do like you know first off i love
the red background you know evokes like
love passion violence so many things you
can get off of that one color palette
but also how everything is sort of
silhouetted but also smeared with that
white clown makeup uh throughout every
little bit of black here i think that is
awesome and you get a little taste of
what the harley quinn costume might
actually look like which is a a classic
hollywood dress so it would seem and and
i appreciate that the silhouette at the
end of the two of them where you do see
like that heart on harley quinn's face
and then the eyes and joker and he's got
the cigarette in hand whole thing has
that classic old-timey feel to it which
is very much complemented by
using this song you know i'll be honest
like the first thing i thought of when i
heard when i was like reminded of where
the song cheek to cheek comes from is
actually uh when i was watching the
trailers for the first joker movie where
you would see arthur fleck and his mom
dancing and the song smile another
old-timey song was playing in the
background of that trailer and it just
started sort of supporting where i feel
like this movie might actually go in
relation to his mom because i actually
think that's what a lot of this movie
might deal with is you know the the
psychological term i believe is
displacement you know arthur fleck
obviously did not have a good
relationship with his mom he's
definitely got some mommy issues right
hearing that this movie is primarily
going to be taking place in arkham
asylum first thing i ever thought when i
heard the rumor that lady gaga was going
to be in this movie i actually think
she'd be a good harleen quinzel and
specifically harleen quinzel because one
thing that i'm i'm hoping and what it
would appear that this movie is doing
this is what i'm really thinking they're
gonna do and i know others have
commentated and sort of echoed the same
sentiment we haven't seen harleen
quinzel
morph into harley quinn slowly over time
in live action we just haven't seen it
yet and if you're going to do a movie
that primarily takes place in arkham
asylum that's what i want this movie to
do really explore early stages the
beginning relationships the bond between
the psychologist and patient and then
watching how the table slowly turn the
connection starts to form the
manipulation starts to happen where you
watch harleen quinzel deteriorate morph
over time into harley quinn hearing this
music knowing kind of the vibe and flair
of the delusions that you know arthur
fleck sort of falls into with the dance
numbers where his mind tends to trail
off dude with the expression of dance
and also the love for the old-timey
films as even explored in the first
joker movie i immediately just start
thinking about his mom and the
unresolved issues there and i feel like
that's where this movie's probably going
to be going down the route of in terms
of the psychological exploration
specifically regarding arthur fleck
because a lot of times in relationships
when it comes to displacement if people
have like some real truly unresolved
issues with their parents that often
gets taken out on their significant
other or their partner someone who they
might because i'm i'm kind of wondering
like what if in this movie they
sometimes it's really up in the air like
does joker actually love harley quinn is
he just abusing her you know depending
on which comic book you're reading or
which medium you're watching it could
just be pure manipulation just wanting a
sense of ownership just liking the
validation of it and sometimes it
actually does really have
real feelings for her but it just comes
out in thwarted ways i think this movie
would be more interesting if it does go
down that route where arthur fleck does
actually have you know a connection with
harleen quinzel but as their bond
becomes stronger he actually becomes
more abusive and why is he becoming more
abusive i could imagine that they are
probably having conversations about his
mom in the therapy sessions before their
love really starts to form and then over
time because you know that's a lot of
issues he hasn't resolved yet so i
imagine like what could start morphing
into a real abusive gaslighting
manipulative relationship
could be him taking out a lot of his
issues that he had with his mom like i
put in some most simplistic terms here
but taking out his issues essentially
with his mom in his relationship with
harleen quinzel and then whatever
traumas you know that harleen quinzel
would have that would cause her to be so
attracted and drawn to someone like
arthur fleck who can take so much
control and advantage of her like we all
know that the relationship between joker
and harley quinn goes down a real dark
depraved path but the backdrop that
they're using is classic hollywood film
here classic hollywood romance
specifically because you know fred
astaire and ginger rogers if i'm not
mistaken they did like nine movies
together they're a classic hollywood
couple and we're thinking about the
musical number to see like this imagery
that they're putting out here is the
musical number is going to be actual
singing one would assume just because
lady gaga's in here that you would get
actual singing music numbers or will it
be a little bit more like just dance
numbers and and it's all just visual
language to watch it is like dream like
a delusion sequences of their love being
this beautiful
escapism romance
but really it's
twisted either flair i think would work
because even if it is singing numbers i
think that would only go to support a
little bit more of that insanity you
know what i mean honestly the the the
little bits that we know about this film
where it's going to be taking place
primarily at arkham asylum knowing it's
going to have some musical numbers the
imagery that they are putting out there
knowing that's going to be focusing on
harley quinn and arthur fleck and
knowing just like the mental health
themes that got to carry over in the
psychological themes that got to carry
over in some fashion i imagine that
there's probably something really rich
in context that we could explore that
truly does make it a genuine sequel to
the first one especially if you are
carrying over those traumatic roots that
he has with his mom watching how it
forms and it becomes a sense of you know
false ownership or taking control with
the relationship with harlan quinzel you
know i think that would be something
very fascinating to explore but that's
just where my mind's going and i just
wanted to share that and i feel like
this imagery kind of only goes to
support my theories what do you guys
think leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell
catch y'all soon
you